one thing i wanted to touch on
that uh really speaks to how much things
have changed is you know you you see uh
cheers now and it's it's replayed you
know all over the world constantly
and what i always appreciate is it has a
theme song
not only does it have a theme song it
has one of the best theme songs ever
but it
is no quick affair you know it is a real
theme song
i think it charted too i think it was up
at the top of the charts that song yeah
everybody knows your name it was going
to the top except
billie jean came out
in 1982 yeah and i couldn't moonwalk
but i was thinking about it i was
thinking about
so much of my uh
childhood
affection is
revolves around these themes theme songs
you know the the get smart theme song uh
hawaii five-o um
uh f-troop
you know i mean that's what an amazing
but just that would tell a story
and an amazing music in these orchestras
wild wild west just incredible
theme songs and you think about
today they're gone
because
you can't spend the time no a show has
to start immediately you can barely show
the title of the show
and that's about it yeah because if you
have a theme song it takes away from
content
and uh uh you can't do it anymore again
cheers said we had 26 minutes to tell a
tale now you only have 21 and a half
minutes so there's no time for a theme
song that's that's you know the theme
song is uh that tells the whole story of
that show
that was it was written by gary portnoy
and judy hart angelo
judy
is the was
is the wife or is the widow of john
angelo who's my close friend
who was an investment banker and wrote
me uh called me and said his wife is
done raising kids she wants to go back
to music writing
can she send you a song
for your show and so that was the song
that i sent and you guys knew right away
when you heard that oh my god yeah oh my
god and you know if you if you google it
the lyrics that were originally written
are really funny lyrics but we we
couldn't do it you can't do a funny
lyrics
every week
you know so that we made it more generic
but it's it's a wonderful song that
encapsulates that show
perfectly
so people for years now have been saying
well the sitcom is dead
and i know that they've said that
repeatedly
uh
off and on for 40 years
you're not buying it
uh me yeah you don't buy that it's that
it's over for the traditional well i've
i've dressed in a dark suit about four
times for the death of sitcoms no no
uh and every time i've gotten to the
funeral they've closed the casket right
so i'm a little concerned now this is
the first time
and i don't know why
studios aren't doing it anymore or
networks aren't doing it anymore even
streamers are not doing it anymore it's
economical
it's
funny the audiences love it they watch
they watch all these shows and reruns
so i don't know i have no
reason why it is
declining so much yeah i you know i've
listened to people try to explain it i
can't explain it
but
uh
selfishly i was there for a golden age
of television when it was
when it was king so
i'm sad now that it's
there are very few there's like the
neighborhood you know uh
cedric the entertainer show and uh
chuck laurie has uh
bob hart's abishela
but i don't know any other sitcoms you
know i had this
thought a couple of years ago maybe more
than a couple years ago but it was um
around the time that you know people
were wondering what's going on with the
the
multi-camera sitcom in front of a live
audience and
i started to wonder if there's a
generation i'm thinking about my kids
that have come of age watching single
camera
no no laughs single camera and that it
becomes and and maybe this comes from
reality television
that it's inculcated in them that that's
the real world
that
a proscenium people making entrances and
there being applause
is not the real world but
the world is portrayed in the office
that looks more like a documentary
and
looks more like
a lot of the content that they've grown
up with feels more
real to them and authentic
uh maybe but friends is still the most
popular show yeah it's you know and
that's in front of a live audience
so
i'm not sure why yeah i'm not sure
you know you need one great sitcom but i
haven't seen it come down to pie kit